foreign
recently have been playing with the
neighbor boy that little boy now comes
up to our house to play says let's play
The Who wants to kill your mom game
when we told him that we weren't gonna
be playing with them anymore my
five-year-old goes yeah it's really sad
that he made that choice I'll get you a
mom of the Year Tessa
[Music]
hey what's going on this is John with
the Dr John Maloney show
sure we'll talk about your mental health
and your marriage and whatever you got
going on in your life parents kids
boundaries
the Mayhem just trying to get up and and
live a good life and uh it's just kind
of hard to do that these days it's not
kind of hard it is hard to do that these
days and that's the purpose of this show
is to walk alongside you and it just so
happens I mean
I mean I don't want to brag but it's the
greatest mental health and parenting
podcast that's ever existed in human
history but besides that
I was gonna say I promise to tell the
truth and I didn't just tell the truth
then but other than that statement my
promise here is I'm gonna sit with you
in the mess Sam and tell the truth and
we're gonna help you figure it out the
the next right step here so let's go oh
you want to uh go go Kelly Daniel like
what do you want to do uh we are going
to do another questions for humans
because
they're still on the ten dollars still
on the ten dollar sale I wish y'all
could hear the things she says in my
ears it's amazing
and by amazing I mean like often I leave
here and go straight to a like a priest
and just like these I heard this today
and he's like you shouldn't be
confessing the other person should be
I'm like I know and then I go straight
from there to therapist what's up Kelly
okay so I just want you to know that we
like 2 000 people this weekend at the
event that saw that I had no tattoos and
now know that you lie about those things
I know just want you to know listen
listen America she hasn't she was super
made up and done up it was really kind
of weird yeah every morning I get up she
had body at three o'clock to put makeup
on my 50 tattoos exactly she was like a
Marvel character this weekend all all
dolled up all right today's question
which famous person would be the most
fun to ask these questions to
so who do you want to sit down with a
box of questions for humans with and
talk
Taylor Swift uh yeah no my answer is not
gonna shock anybody in this room it is a
hundred percent Taylor Swift of all the
people in the world of all the people in
the world yes why honestly if you ever
she lives right down the street from
here like like okay if you ever watch
any of her interviews honestly she is
actually really funny like she has a
good sense of humor and I just love the
way her mind works and she's so smart
like I you're laughing but it's true I
would love to I would also like to say
Sarah had a really good answer she said
Robin Williams and I'm like I could have
stolen that but I didn't because I'm
true to myself and I'm gonna stick with
Taylor Swift
Benjamin I'm gonna go Stephen Colbert I
think he would be really fun to do that
because he's hilarious but he's also got
some great insights he's very very smart
he's very he's a nerd like me yeah yeah
I think I'm gonna pick Dave Grohl okay
because I think he's very smart and he's
very very funny yeah and I think he
would just have some great I mean think
about
with you know grunge and just I think
he'd have some great stories to tell and
I could see him being the kind of guy
that would actually sit down and just
tell you all these funny crazy wacky
stories
what do you think Nate Dogg
uh I think that I would probably either
go with Ryan Reynolds or Conan O'Brien
both their humor really just slays me Oh
I thought it was because like y'all
haven't seen this but Nate was changing
in the back in the dressing room and he
has a huge tattoo of Ryan Reynolds on
his chest which I was caught off guard
by but his hand that guy's good looking
I'll give you that one you know it I
I'll give you that I think we all kind
of get that one we're all like yeah that
makes sense but I like how you kind of
Twisted it just now to say like not
because it is a smoke show but like he's
really interesting and funny so that's
why you want to talk to him
he is funny yeah and a smoke show and
both and I want to have a table
actually I want to have I would want to
do these with Jesus right besides that
I did you just Jesus took us I wish you
could see Kelly's face it was incredible
that's why I did that I want to sit down
at the table
and around the table I'd like to have uh
Rich Mullins Tim Keller Jon Stewart and
Dave Chappelle and Robin Williams and
I'd like to just sit down because I
think there'd be a lot of you know who
else Phil and Selmo I want the lead
singer of Pantera at that table I want
to just
hear what you guys have to say about
some stuff because y'all have seen the
dark and the light and I think that
would be a a fun interaction
that's what I think
in fact I'm gonna try to make that
happen
that's not ever gonna happen oh boy hey
uh real quick your five star reviews
mean the world Subs hit the Subscribe
button just hit the Subscribe button
please hit the Subscribe button and pass
this show on to people that you care
about and for the greatest supplements
that me and my family use almost
exclusively go to thorn.com you the
letter U slash deloni for 25 off
everything thorn.com t-h-o-r-n-e
thorn.com you slash deloni all right
let's go out to Houston Texas and talk
to Tony all right hey Tony
how's it going what's up man
thanks for taking my call you got it all
right so let me fill everybody in here
um
Jenna
when was he when was this original call
uh my my wife called in a couple a
couple months ago okay wife calls it a
couple months ago
and I made some sort of statement like I
wish your husband would call me
something like that right and then here
you are
yes sir awesome so number one
you're a courageous guy and I'm it's
it's an honor to get to talk to you okay
most people shirk away and you said no
I'll talk to that dude so good for you
man the second thing is was if I
remember correctly this call was about
hidden money and emotional like all kind
of stuff and I made some pretty bold
statements that I didn't believe the
story she was telling me or the story
that you had told her that she was not
telling me
and so you had the courage to call so
good for you man so let's uh let's just
jump in so tell me you heard the call
and all that right
I did I've listened to it uh
a bunch of times okay so tell me what's
going on in y'all's world
um
I mean am I to to recap or just just
keep moving go move forward go for it
man recap it and then let's uh we can we
can figure out what happens next
well
um
you know it started by
uh you know me trying to start a company
and
um the company not really generating as
much money as I needed it to and
at the time we had separate bank
accounts we we basically had
a financial roommate situation where we
pooled all our money for our bills and
then all the rest of the money was just
hours
so
like what you made what you made was
yours what she made was hers
but all of our bills our mortgage our
insurance all that stuff we just threw
it all into the middle and whatever was
left was ours which you know after going
through the Ramsey plan it was just a
terrible thing that we did for a very
long time sure gotcha
and so you had did you have a separate
business account for this business you
were trying to start or would you just
Reese running out of the family checking
account
uh that and credit cards and just trying
to get it up off the ground what kind of
business was it
it's just remodeling I build houses and
I you know I can flip houses for people
and
you know there's a lot of money that
churns in it but if you if you take an
extra month on the project you may not
make any money that's right so did you
find yourself having to get money for
the next job to float this job and kind
of get in that loop-de-loop
you know Ponzi scheme kind of thing and
and I didn't let it affect the household
because I I was so adamant that this
thing was going to take off
so I took care of everything on the
business side but you know I didn't rack
up sixty thousand dollars to do that at
one time it was a it was debt by a
thousand purchases it wasn't these big
purchases
and you were you were right when you
said that they were purses and trips and
hotels the only difference was
um those were all purchases for my wife
they were to keep up the appearance that
everything was going good because in my
mind I knew like right around the corner
I was going to hit this you know this
big job and it was just gonna wipe all
this away and
things are going to be great and that
that big job never came
so whenever somebody tells me hey I
discovered this huge amount of debt that
my partner has my wife has it or my
husband has it
and
I asked what they spend it on
and they can't tell me oh it was on a
tractor or it was on like all sudden my
house with my garage just covered in
DeWalt tools
um
no I I bought that dude so almost always
not 100 but almost always somebody's
having an affair has someone had
something on the side
and this money is just racking up and
she never told me anything about
suddenly she was getting all these gifts
and and things she did she just leave
that part out
it wasn't that she was getting the gifts
it's that
I never made her we went from our
lifestyle never changed
so when my income dropped significantly
our lifestyle didn't change and I was
making up for that with
with credit and when Christmas would
come around
I would blow it out of the water
like I had before and
take until
June to pay all the Christmas off and
then minimum payment all the other stuff
and then
you know after the Christmas is paid off
then
if we wanted Sushi or go to did dinner
or to do this or that I you know and I
didn't have enough like
liquid funds I I just have a hard time
saying no to her so I just would always
take care of it
and so it wasn't a matter of you
spending sixty thousand is that what the
number one 60 80 something like that
yeah I mean it it went it was a roller
coaster it was up and down and up and
down because I would
you know
you get a job and you spend a whole
bunch of money on that job and you get
another job and spend a whole bunch of
money on that job right well and then I
went back I went back to work for a home
builder so I had regular paychecks again
and
and then I would do a big job but if I
did a big job and she knew how much I
made that money didn't go towards the
debt that she didn't know about it went
into our emergency fund so if oh here's
ten thousand dollars oh great we can put
that in our emergency fund so dude you
sound exactly
like somebody juggling women on the side
you know that right
I I do but there was no woman on the
side until until six seven months ago
and it wasn't a woman on the side it was
like we you know I was in therapy before
I was in therapy trying to get my life
to also go to marriage counseling
but do you but do you do you understand
do you understand
that you're
you're running this this hustle on the
side
you have literally a second life a life
that is failing financially of life that
is covered up in shame and you're just
scared to death
and then you bring that energy into your
household
and your wife you have little ones
I do okay everybody feels that there's a
machine running inside that dude's chest
and they start figuring out it must be
me it must be something else it must be
that I'm not doing this enough I'm not
doing and it gets people just start it
starts with an inch they just move a
little bit away in a little bit more
away and then you feel that and you try
to spin that machine even faster they
feel that they move further and further
and further away so this thing starts
pretty innocuously
right it start it starts
like oh I didn't make it anything on
that job I lost two thousand dollars on
that job
and then your heartbeat kicks up two
beats a minute
it's a little more stress then a little
more I gotta get another job gotta get
another one gotta get another one you
get one sweet and then you end up losing
five grand on that one
and it just builds and builds
and the whole time when you're saying I
didn't want you to go to marriage
counseling
you see how this was this was after
after the diagnosis after she found out
about the woman at work
um I I went back I went back to therapy
and then I wanted to go with her and
she was she was apprehensive and
I you know
I when we had already gotten through the
financial stuff when when the
the co-workers stuff started we had
she found out we we found the Ramsay
plan we combined all of our accounts we
cleared out all of that debt including
all of our cars and everything we worked
that free except for the house that we
have and the lot that we own
and and we have a substantial investment
and a substantial you know because she
has a
chronic disease we have substantial uh
emergency funds hey Tony Tony yeah
hopefully by now you know this isn't
about money
I'm I'm well aware okay
yeah because I I
when she got diagnosed I panicked
because she you know there were
complications and she was pregnant with
my daughter and
um immediately I I went into I have to
do all the things that I can do to give
her as much time with the kids as
possible to do the things that I'm doing
so I remodeled the house
we could have a nicer house and
you know I I tried to give her every
second with it with the kids
and I drove a huge wedge in between us
right
where she's she's doing bath time on
dishes I find out you know two years
later oh I wish we would have just could
have switched off because
what you're giving me is is hard but I
thought what I was giving her was was
what could potentially be taken away
that's right
and that that wedge is what
our our friendship
not not our on our Merit but but the two
of us being friends yeah
and then that's where I
I it wasn't even
I wasn't even really aware of it that I
was seeking a friendship outside of my
marriage
and
so bring me bring me to bring me to
right now
so I mean
right now I've
I've printed out every I've gone to the
credit card companies and had them send
all the bank statements all the credit
cards hold on hold on let's get before
that let's get before that
okay
what you have is a long pattern
of trying to love your wife
trying to take care of your wife and
your kids
in the way that you think they need to
be taken care of
have you sat down with your wife and
said how can I love you today
yeah we've just recently done that okay
so what you have is you've got four
years or whatever the number is of
trying to create a business that would
make a jillion dollars and I would even
go as far to say is you want to be a
successful entrepreneur
but just talking to you I think you want
to be a guy that gives your wife
whatever she wants in the world
yeah and that you want to give your kids
whatever they want in the world
so much so that you will ignore math
you'll ignore reality because I'm gonna
make this thing happen for them
right
and then you want to be such a great dad
I'm Gonna Make this House amazing for my
wife and kids I've heard her I've seen
what she's watching
out of the corner of her eye on HGTV I'm
gonna give her that
I see how much she's how hard she's
working with these kids I'm gonna make
sure there's not a dish in the sink I'm
gonna make sure there's not a scrap of
trash I'm gonna take it out every day
I'm gonna make sure the lawn is perfect
I'm gonna do all this stuff for her
because I love her so much
and she's sitting in there saying God I
wish he would just come help with a bath
yeah right and so
um
there's there is there does come a
moment when
people need friends
and co-workers especially co-workers
you're attracted to that's that's a
whole thing it happens all the time I'm
not going to beat you up for that okay
you know right
yeah it just never happened to me I ever
expect to be in that situation nobody
expects that okay and here we are
what I'm afraid is gonna happen is
you're gonna quit
because you've been working so hard for
years
and all it's got you is a wife who
doesn't like you
and kids who are like Ugh
because Dad's always stressed and Dad's
always exhausted and Mom's always mad at
dad and dad always whatever
see that's the thing in the last
two months
we've
we've gone to counseling we've had
before we even went to counseling we had
that discussion about
why what I was doing was dividing us and
we went to work on that and I just
stepped back and just treated her normal
because she said well you're doing all
this stuff and you're treating me like
I'm disabled
so I stepped back and I just we we just
take care of everything together and
things have gotten a lot better but
there's you know there's just
I just want to I want to give I want to
be able to like you said I want to be
able to make the ground underneath her
solid and I want to make her feel safe
that's what I want perfect
let her tell you that because it's
really easy to listen to that last call
and be like I'm going to prove to you
and maybe she didn't ask for you to
prove to her
or maybe instead of running out and
printing off every receipt and spending
hours and she's saying what are you
doing you're like I'm just trying to get
the instead of that
just to say hey
I did something for years
it was dishonest and wasn't true
and it doesn't matter why I was doing it
because I was trying to give you the
world it doesn't matter what matters is
I did it and I'm so sorry
and then asking her
what is the next step that I can do for
you to help rebuild trust I'm gonna let
you speak into that and for some folks
it's I need to see your phone every day
okay
for some folks it's I need to see all
the credit card okay
for some folks it's every morning before
you go to work I want to look you in the
eyes and we're going to talk about what
we each need that day
everybody's different
but the key here is where everybody's
the same and this deal is you have to
stop trying to solve all her problems or
completely disengaging you got to stay
in gear but you got to ask her what do
you need what are you today and she's
probably even gonna know sometimes I
don't know
okay cool I'm gonna check in four times
and what you're doing right now man is
all you're doing is taking that energy
and that love and that commitment that
you have for her and you're channeling
it like a laser
right into her heart and she's gonna
tell you how to get there
because Instagram can't tell you the way
your dad did it can't tell you she is
that's your wife
you see that you see the difference
yes
and bro I almost lost it all doing the
exact same thing
okay and I want to tell you on the other
side of this
everything in my marriage in my life is
different because I start the day with
how can I love you today
Everything Changes
because now I've got some direction for
this chaotic energy in this insane
amount of love and respect that I have
for my wife now I've got a place to to
channel it because before it was all
over the place
so did she does she still want to be
married to you
yeah right now I guess okay
you're gonna have to dust your your
pants off and stand back up
because you're talking like a guy that
got knocked out
well she's always been my everything and
I have not had support because I can't
turn to her for that support right now I
don't I don't have a
Network to lean on well two things
number one that's your job to go get
that
okay
number two
um this this doesn't work if it's
one-sided all the way
if you go groveling around on your hands
and knees saying I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry and she's like hmm that doesn't
work
the conversation is how can I love you
better today what do you need for me
today and then she has to ask that
question back to you
how can I love you today
and sometimes your answer might be
um man I would love just to spend a
little time with with you and not the
kids
sometimes it might be I'm actually
really good right now can we just watch
a show tonight after the kids are in bed
sometimes it's I miss you we haven't had
sex in like two weeks You Wanna Party
like it can be whatever
but you've got to be honest and stated
out loud and just say it
and I think I've said this on the show
before I can't tell you how embarrassed
I was and now I'm embarrassed that I was
embarrassed because it's stupid
but it was after 15 or 16 years of being
married and things got really rough
that I finally said out loud I worked so
hard for you I wish you would just say
the words I'm proud of you
I think we're in I'm in a similar
situation okay you've got to say that
out loud
and you also have to be willing to admit
I did some things that I'm not proud of
in an effort to keep up appearances
I will never lie to you again
I'll never hide from you again you see
how that's radically different that's a
new identity I'm gonna tell you things
even when I don't know how
and I'm going to ask for Grace on the
back end of those conversations but I'm
not ever going to hide a thing from you
again
and that means you have to deal with
shame that means you have to deal with
when things go wrong or you get fired or
you get in trouble or you don't get the
promotion you thought you were gonna get
you gotta go home and say it
and then she's gonna feel safe not that
oh no we lost a job she's gonna feel
safe that that guy tells the truth I can
anchor into that guy and we are gonna
figure out what happens next together
that's marriage
that's not one dude trying to be a hero
trying to save everything
now I'll say this I think your marriage
um
is going to be extraordinary
because I think you're all in
and I think you've got the passion and
the love and the connectivity with this
woman
and if you've told me the truth and I'm
I'm not see I I can't see you so I'm
just gonna uh I'm gonna take out your
word
if you're a guy's been telling the truth
take it one step further and say I know
what I did was wrong and I'm sorry
I will never lie to you again
how can I love you today and it sounds
so Elementary
you should I should be able to know how
to love my wife you don't
most of us don't
I should be able to meet my husband's
needs you don't know you can't if he
doesn't tell you what they are
if y'all will practice those steps
little bitty steps there's going to be
some days that this comes crashing back
on her and she gets sad and upset and
frustrated that's okay that happens
that's life there's gonna be some days
that you wake up and you're bathing in
shame because I should be so much
further ahead in my career financially
that's fine that'll happen
so I need a couple of buddies that you
can call go hang out with
commit
how can I love you today
and
here's how you can love me today
it's an incredible dance
it's incredible dance
we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
somebody's favorite segment
s are your friends
Arrow music
our personality tests accurate
our online mental health assessments
worth the zeros and ones they are
printed on the internets
oh boy all right so get your
um
I don't believe you get them all ready
because here we go
can you trust personality tests is the
name of this article from psychology
psychology today our personality tests
accurate from Psychology today
betterhelp.com personality test accuracy
and practical uses on and on and on and
on there are a million of them
Myers-Briggs let's see here the disc
assessment Winslow hexaco big five
little five there's not a little five
but
um
there's also I'm gonna lump these all
into a bucket here there's also
you used to let me say this way it used
to be the DSM the diagnostic and
statistical manual
the manual that medical practitioners
mental health practitioners use to make
mental health diagnosis it's a it's a
big medical book
it's got diagnostic codes in it it's got
all this medical language and jargon it
used to be like when I was in grad
school we had to spend I don't know a
couple hundred bucks I think to get to
get it and you have to learn how to read
it and you got to learn how to use it
now it's just on the internet
everybody so there's there's no context
anymore everything's stripped of context
and it's just Googling do I have ADHD
and here's a 10 question quiz on
Facebook or do I have borderline
personality disorder and
comorbid anxiety and major depressive
disorder and I'm just going to Google it
and then there's these tests you can
take online
while you're on the toilet and it will
just tell you like oh
I got um
post-traumatic stress disorder or I've
got
I know agoraphobia whatever the thing is
so
here's my thoughts on these and we've
talked about them a little bit um in the
past and so I want to be pretty clear
about it here's some things uh let me
look at some of these things we printed
off here
um a 2018 article in Scientific American
offered a harsh review of Myers-Briggs
and other personality tests
eventually they're saying there is zero
signs to back them up none
none
some have come back and said well I mean
that article was a little bit harsh
there's some stuff there is some utility
there there is some good information out
there there's no study saying that
they're not great
another
here's I'm gonna I'm just gonna take a
quick left turn here
I can go through all these but I think
I'm Gonna Save Us a whole bunch of time
here's the deal on personality tests
on online mental health diagnostic tools
number one they can be fun
it can be fun
when I have my magical time and I'm late
for the 17th time that day for something
can be fun to ask myself what is wrong
with me into Google do I have ADHD and
to take a 10 question thing
or maybe by now they maybe even uploaded
some of the uh clinical assessments
cool that can be fun
they can also give a baseline for
conversation so I can go to my therapist
and say hey I took this 10 question
thing it said I scored a 10 out of 10 on
ADHD
I would love to find out if this is what
I have and I learned love to learn about
ADHD and then more importantly learn
how I can live my life based on this
on this new insight great cool
they should not be used in any sort of
concrete predictive way
same with personality tests I'm an ENFP
or an istj or whatever the thing is cool
it's a self-reporting tool it's the way
you think you show up in the world and
by the way every time I've given one of
those every time I've taken one I mean
every time I've taken one of those
strengths whatever the thing is people
around me always say John no you don't
you do it like this
and I think man I came on I come on
really hard when I answer questions I'm
harsh and they'll say like the nicest
guy I know or I'll say like I'm like the
nicest guy I know and they're like ah
you're kind of the worst right other
people other people are often infinitely
more reflective about how you show up in
the world because they experience you
and so
they can be fun but they shouldn't be
used in some predictive way you
shouldn't not hire somebody because they
have the wrong letters from an internet
test
you shouldn't fire somebody because they
have the wrong letters from the internet
test
that's poor management it's poor
leadership
you should not marry somebody because of
the wrong Enneagram number
you should not marry somebody because
they have different big fives than you
do or a different love language than you
do
don't use these for diagnostic tools
only use them for a reflection
for looking in the mirror and going huh
that feels like it Nails me
feels like it sums it up
that's a good thing in our culture we
are terrible about being reflective
we're so concerned with how other people
make us feel we're so in concerned with
our latest outrage the the latest thing
we are
um
you know offended by
the way I was having this conversation
this weekend with a friend
in the new attention economy so let's
say 150 years ago yeah the town crier
you had the kid that came out on the
corner you know with the newspaper
saying here ye hear ye here's what's
going on in the world
and you had to get up and go see what
was going on you had to bring your
attention to the info
now there news is everywhere it's just
pumped into your head 24 7 365. it's on
every screen and I'm beginning to wonder
if the the way I counteract in the past
the way I counteracted the world the way
I handled the world is by getting the
information now
the way I protect myself
is to walk away
in an attention economy the greatest way
I can hurt somebody's business isn't to
comment on everything and to stamp and
scream and yeah still walk away
just to walk away
but that's about being reflective how do
you show up how do you answer how do you
feel when you how do you experience the
world cool these things are good for
that they're good to discuss with
friends and colleagues to get some ideas
on how you might be viewing yourself
incorrectly or on how you can double
down on the things that you're good at
that's awesome that's very good it's
very good I never understood I was uh
one of the strings quests was a
maximizer
until until I took that thing
and it said you're a maximizer you look
at somebody's idea and you say man this
could be this
I never thought of that I was right
I do feel that way a lot that doesn't
mean I don't have my own ideas that
doesn't mean my maximization is always
correct that doesn't mean I have
permission to be late to everything the
number of times I especially when like
strings Quest first came out and I would
have an employee and be like hey you've
been late five days in a row like hey
sorry bro I'm a maximizer I gotta wait
till the good ideas are there and then I
no you gotta be on time
got me on time
so let me say this
profoundly and boldly never diagnose
yourself from the internet ever ever
ever ever always see a professional
medical or mental health practitioner
full stop end of story
don't don't don't get on the internet at
2 A.M when your can't sleep and start
googling because you're gonna figure out
you've got 40 different Diagnostics
40 different quote-unquote mental health
issues which don't even like that word
in addition to training professionals
have wisdom
we've seen lots and lots of other people
if you go back and listen to this show
over the last couple of years the one
thing I love to bring to people
is social norming you're not crazy
there's a whole bunch of people
experiencing the world just like you
you're not broken your body's just
trying to take care of you
so a mental health practitioner can
contextualize something you may feel
like you are out of control they'll look
at you and go you're good you're good I
asked one of the guys who trained me
recently he was in town Nashville Dr
Young and we had dinner
and I said hey is like once and for all
I trust trust him is oppositional
defined disorder is that real I I hear
data on one side I hear conversations
with practitioners on the other side
here's what he said he said yep it's
real and you've never seen it
I said what do you mean I've never seen
it I've seen fifth graders and
five-year-olds losing their mind
and he said until you've been in a psych
ward and there's six grown men unable to
hold down a seven-year-old
who's literally able to pull a door off
of its hinge like it's real you've
probably never seen it that's the
difference between or go to work when
you do uh your your mental health
um degree in your mental health graduate
degree and you go do some time in uh
a psychiatric hospital or a
um
you know mental health ward
oh
that's what major depression looks like
there's context there
don't go to the internet
okay
we used to know who we were in
relationship to others
one of the most Brilliant Minds I think
is a guy named Andrew Peterson he's a
songwriter and author he says your
community defines your calling
your community the people you love and
interact with and talk to and experience
every day will tell you
man you you're not going to want a job
where all you do is budgets sitting at a
table all day you're gonna go crazy
you don't need some
some faceless mindless computer program
to tell you what your personality is
ask the people around you
ask your friends if you don't have those
people let this be a sign go get those
people in your life
find a mentor that will tell you dude I
I think your strengths are this let's
discuss that let's have these
conversations real people and real
friends
so
have fun with personality exams or
personality tests have fun with them
get online and see with one of these
internet quizzes if you might have
generalized anxiety disorder cool
ask a friend
and then go see a professional
go talk to somebody with training and
expertise and wisdom and content
that's the path to getting well
not trying to solve this with the
internet
we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
let's go out to Tessa in Coeur d'Alene
what's up Tessa how we doing
hey John how's
it I mean literally could not be better
how are you
excellent first off I want to say thank
you yoshima has made me a better person
a better wife and a better mom
that's the nicest thing I think anyone's
ever said to me and my wife even said I
do and this what you just said I think
was nice man it's true you've got me out
of my box for sure and made me think
about things I never thought I could
well you Hey listen I run my mouth on a
podcast in on a YouTube you actually are
out there doing it so thank you you're
the hero here man it's awesome so what's
up Sean
so as you would say I think I found
myself in a situation not by my hand
or yeah not by him but in my lap oh no
what happened
um my kids recently have been playing
with the neighbor boy which we've lived
in this house for seven years only have
a seven and a five-year-old
and they've just started noticing the
neighborhood across the street who moved
in about six months after us so
basically the whole time we've been here
okay
um he's nine
so as of like two weeks ago we thought
okay like they started noticing him they
could probably play together as long as
I felt comfortable as long as I could
see my kids and they were on my property
so we're from five acre Parcels out kind
of in
no nowhere okay that's where that's
where I'm at so you don't you don't you
don't have a relationship like with the
parents and whatnot
um up to this point it's all been a
negative relationship with the parents
they've called the cops on us because my
dog goggles are chickens after I had
reached out to them I mean it's kind of
I mean you got to call the cops that's
their chicken okay I'm just kidding so I
saw that that chicken so I text them I
was like hey do you have chickens I just
found chicken like we'll make it right
no response the cops just got called
and what's the lesson here Tessa just
eat the chicken Jesus
that's not good I'm sorry okay so yeah
um so you all aren't super tight but
then your daughters who are seven is
that right
yeah five and seven okay and you see
this handsome little neighbor boy this
is how Dawson's Creek starts by the way
and right so then you say it's cool but
they got to be on your place
yeah so our property opens up
to their house
a very open field we have a playset
trampoline all like the cool stuff you
know so it's like okay come over here
you guys can play as long as I can see
you and if they're riding their bikes
they have walkie talk to you so like we
can communicate yeah
um and so they start playing with this
little white salt
I need your help John to figure out
where is the line on calling in the
troops versus just kind of keeping an
eye on the situation yeah so
um a couple days ago they were out
playing with him and another little
neighbor boy down the street Drives By
in his dad's truck
and
the neighbor across the street goes I
want to kill him
and my girls are like uh I'm not totally
sure the situation getting five and
seven reeling it to me
but then that same day within within
like a half hour time frame that little
boy now comes up to our house to play
and
the boy number one let's call him
so let's play The Who wants to kill your
mom game
and this call is taking a draft a turn I
was not I I thought you were gonna say
like your daughters thought this boy was
cute not that he was
like okay this is a really like serious
situation for sure yeah and like over
the weekend my daughter came to me so
like kind of a little a little more
history on this my daughter came to me
and said hey Mom I want to shoot a bird
or can we shoot Birds something like
that and I was like wait we don't just
shoot animals to kill animals we we
shoot to provide for our family but we
don't just shoot to kill and I was like
but if you want to shoot a gun up like
um we can talk we can shoot targets like
we have Targets in the backyard like a
safe area when dad comes home we can
totally go through targets I was like
but we don't shoot animals just to kill
an animal
so like
I'm learning that she got that from him
my daughter's like well the neighbor boy
says he goes in his backyard and shoots
Birds yeah
yeah and then last summer
um we saw him riding his bike with a BB
gun in his hands and he actually shot a
dog on my property that was tied up just
hanging out yeah
so I'm like I'm like oh my gosh so now
all these like stars are lining and then
who wants to shoot your mom game fast
forward back to this other day
it's the two boys I guess and my girls
are there these boys are nine and ten so
older than my kids
and they said who wants to play the
shoot your mom game and they said raise
your hand if you want to shoot your mom
and then both boys raise their hand and
my son just goes mom we didn't raise our
hands
thank you I appreciate that yeah
um
yeah this is the situation I find myself
in is where do I go because
we live out in the middle of Idaho
we all have guns it's so it's just the
way it is
basically locked up sure I don't know if
my neighbor has a Shotgun by his front
door
that his kid to get could get to you
know or like
I don't know what happens in their house
all I know is what happens in mine right
and that's really all you can protect
right
right so so let's walk backwards here
okay okay and I think you've got a um a
good moment in time right now
um yeah are your kids in school
they are okay is this little boy go to
school
say that again does this little boy go
to school
yes they actually go to different
schools my kids are in a charter school
and he goes to the public school okay
so that might be your best friend right
now so in a normal situation and I I
actually think
um
I I think it's
if you have a great relationship with
your neighbor or a terrible relationship
with your neighbor
something like this is not going to hurt
it either way because it just is okay
right
and so
as a parent no matter how sideways
things get and I also understand rural
communities and there's just people that
live out on their land and don't want
nobody on their land and you know I they
just do life very very differently okay
I get that I live out in the woods too
so
um
I do think and I just want to I just
wanna I think there's a Humane thing
which is I'm gonna tell Mom and Dad hey
your son's talking about guns shot a dog
on a property like talking about killing
your mom talking about shooting and
killing a neighbor boy like in the world
we live in now I just need to make you
all aware of that and they may tell you
to go to hell you get off our property
what are you some kind of liberal free
like they can say all that stuff that's
a that's a that's how they get to choose
how they respond
they may abuse this little boy and beat
the tar out of him how dare you how
whatever or maybe maybe they say oh he's
he's picking up a lot more we need to
get these guns locked up
yeah probably not but maybe right and so
I think that's the place where we're
gonna start I would not when I say I
wouldn't let my kids play with him
that was one of my other questions too
yeah um and here's the thing I think
your seven-year-old and I think your
five-year-old are
old enough for you to say very basically
my job is to keep you safe and if boys
are talking about shooting people and
wanting to kill people then you will not
be playing with them
it's my job to keep you safe and so you
are making yourself the bad guy and you
are making yourself the the responsible
parent putting a boundary up okay and I
I would just hold to it and if he comes
over I would say hey we're we're not
gonna we're not playing right now thank
you so much
and he needs to go home
okay
you've made me a better mom
my kids when I told them
I basically asked them um what's my job
as a mom and they both said to keep us
safe yeah
and then when we told them that we
weren't gonna be playing with them
anymore my seven-year-old Joe's mom it
doesn't it's not just sad for him it's
sad for us and my five-year-old goes
yeah it's really sad that he made that
choice ah look at you Mom of the Year
Tessa so I was honestly shocked when
they put the blame on him and not on us
they they understand that he's choosing
to not play with y'all because he's
talking about killing people
right now here's the I think I I
maybe I'm cynical at this point in my
life I I don't think the conversation
with mom and dad's gonna go great I just
don't
um
and it may just not go great
but I think it's worth having it
nonetheless and even tell them we love
your kid we love your son it's all good
but in this day and age I just we just
need to say something
the second thing is
um and let me let me tell you this let
me back up a little bit so as a as a
school administrator which I was or as a
crisis responder here's what I'm always
looking for I'm always looking for
Trends particularly escalations or
de-escalations okay
so you got a kid who makes a throwaway
statement I want to kill that kid well
that can be a rural hillbilly I'm gonna
kill that guy right that can be his mom
and dad yelling at the I'm gonna kill
that politician kind of stuff that could
just be rural speak
then who wants to play I want to kill my
mom game
and then I'm going around and there's
some language about violence escalation
in kids and it starts with herding
animals and it escalates from it
escalates in size two and I'm shooting
the neighbor's dog just not to not even
here's the thing not even to kill it or
not even to eat it it's just to watch it
hurt
right I'm shooting an animal just to
shoot it now we're getting into this
Psychopathology we're moving over into
like what I'm seeing is I'm feeling as
you're telling me this an escalation
here right and when you look back almost
every active shooter let me put a caveat
no no one's saying this kid's gonna be
an active shooter but when you look
backwards
the number of people who come out from
the woodwork could be like oh they told
me this or they texted me this or I knew
about this or they mentioned this or
they just bought that
every very very rare just something just
come out of the blue once people have
are able to look back and see all the
puzzle pieces that they weren't putting
together because they didn't know they
were having a puzzle okay so I think
there there's an escalation here that is
that demands your intervention so good
for you
I think your main intervention is going
to be with the school
and that was gonna be my question too
yes I would call the school counselor
and say I'm the mother of a
five-year-old and a seven-year-old who
go to x School our neighbor plays they
go to your school
um he's made multiple suggestions that
he's going to
kill a schoolmate kill a mom he shot
things with a BB gun on my property he's
talking to my kids about just shooting
animals
um in this day and age I just want to
make you guys aware
and they may not even be able to because
of uh FERPA federal education rights and
privacy they may not even be able to
confirm he's a student there cool that's
their deal but you'll know I let them
know and here's where that's a gift for
them
they may have a teacher who put in a
file this kid keeps talking about
shooting everybody
and they may have a PE teacher that had
to pull him aside and say so you're
you're adding a data point to an entire
picture that they have on this
particular young young man
or it may be the first time and then
they're going to reach out to the
teachers and say you guys have any
worries about this kid and they're gonna
be like oh yeah this gets crazy you
should read this poem he wrote or the
story he wrote and suddenly you're able
to head something off at the pass
okay
hear what I'm saying
yeah I actually so I
um I'm in the community right now like
I'm a board member on like a foster care
um
organization here and one of our board
members is a mental health specialist in
the school district and so I reached out
to her and she she also recommended
contacting CPS as well as the school
okay would you recommend CPS at this
point too
um
I mean I
touch a touchy subject like that
yeah um here's what I'm I'm never gonna
do is well I say never sometimes there's
just idiots but
um I'm if you have a local mental health
practitioner that suggests that their
CPS
needs to be involved in this than I
would
okay
um or if you have any sense that you've
got parents that you're dealing with
that
um
don't care what their kids do and their
kids coming over your house at 11 30 p.m
or kids out there shooting stuff at 4am
right it's just there's the kid is
basically feral right he's got No
Boundaries no no adult intervention in
his life at all then yes because because
what we're with CPS what we're looking
at Child Protective Services is is there
neglect or is there abuse going on are
parents not doing their due diligence
with a child and letting the kid run
around and go I'll even say this in this
for those of you who live in Suburban
neighborhoods or who live in like in big
cities nine-year-old kids with a BB gun
out on a five acre
Farm is not weird it's just not weird
um and I know that sounds bizarre um but
it's just it's not weird
but shooting a dog on a neighbor's
property is is
like like to put that in perspective
I don't think like my son hunts with me
my son I mean I've tried to teach him at
a very very young age
um all the safety and all the stuff I
don't think it would even enter his mind
like it would that would be like an
alien invasion that would never come
into his brain to shoot a dog right
especially a neighbor's dog especially
just like it would never it's not it's
not a normal thought process is what I'm
saying
okay so there's something not right
um if you're local if your local mental
health supervisor says you can call CPS
then call CPS
um if if I'm I would probably lean on
doing that after I talk to the parents
because you'll gauge their response
although and know this it's a
declaration of war for Neighbors
right you know you can call it cops on
my kids I mean then it's just a whole
other it's Hatfield and McCoys at that
point
um
yeah I actually already called the
non-emergency hotline okay
um and and they said well where you live
honestly all we deal with is
domestic violence and drunk driving yeah
that this because you didn't have a gun
in his hand when he said those words
that's right
there's no immediate threat rule America
gets the short end on a lot of sticks
man
right yeah super under resourced and a
lot of mental health challenges and a
lot of addiction a lot of just innate
generational struggles man
that uh there's not a lot of people
looking at the children saying hey if we
if we invest here if we get involved
here we can stop a whole lot of
Downstream challenges but
um
yeah I mean
I'm hesitant here's why I'm hesitant
because I just know that this this is
going to be tough on y'all
right and the chances of him being a
serial killer are are statistically very
very low
but we're in a day and age where we have
to make that phone call now
yeah
and we have to have that conversation
and
um
I hate that you're in that position
yeah that's
kind of taking over my whole week as you
can imagine yeah so let me give you some
wisdom there when these kind of things
spin up I would get out a note card or a
piece of paper and write down the four
or five phone calls you need to make and
put little tiny boxes next to them and
just start making those phone calls
because right now what you're gonna say
and who you're gonna call and how it
just starts to take over your whole body
yeah and you're watching a show and then
you're Googling who should I call and
you're like your husband's like wants to
hang out and party and you're like well
and you're scrolling like it just kind
of takes you it just pulls you away from
it from life
so yeah I'd put it on there just go out
the conversation across the street just
go ahead and talk to the school and
maybe the school will call CPS
and they can hold some of that
um
they can hold some of that
responsibility or at this point honestly
when I just I mean what goes on in my
community just recently I I don't care
about the blame anymore I just want kids
to be safe I'm just kind of tired of it
yeah it really sucks because I mean
I'm sure I I don't I'm sure he's a good
kid
he's a kid yeah that's right I would
love for him to like be able to just
hang out and play like I can't subject
my kids to it though and that's like the
thing I keep tossing back and forth my
head is kids are kids and I just want to
love them because they're kids
but I also can't put my kids in that
situation you have you have a
responsibility to your family and to
your kids to keep them safe and the
extension as by having kids one of the
things I say all the time is my kids are
your kids and your kids are my kids man
I need your kids to be safe too
and so because I'm a parent in the
community I
also have to make sure that I'm doing
what I can in my limited role I'm not
overzealous and I'm not trying to
control what I can't control but
I'm going to do my part to make sure the
other kids in the community are safe too
and at this point
when you've got a kid across the street
who has shown that he's just going to
recklessly shoot animals that he brags
about killing things just to kill them
when he talks about killing some a
classmate when he talks about killing
his mom and want to play a game about
killing his mom and he's trying to
recruit like
um
yeah it's just time to make some phone
calls
time to make some phone calls
the one thing I'll walk back and again
this um I'm thinking about all this in
real time
I I do have a
um
I do have a policy just a personal
policy that I only talk when I can be
heard I only speak when I can be heard
and if you get in a few seconds that
your neighbors have no interest in
talking to you get off our property you
scumbag we don't want to talk to you
whatever
um
then they're choosing to not engage with
you in a very difficult conversation
that needs to be had and I'll honor that
but I'm gonna go do what I need to do
and I'm gonna call the school I'm gonna
call CPS I'm gonna call my local mental
health authorities and I'm gonna make
sure this kid gets the help that he
needs before he hurts himself or he
hurts a whole bunch of other people
you are Mom of the Year Tessa your mom
of the year
thank you so much for loving your kids
loving your community and loving that
little nine-year-old boy that's living
across the street
let me know how it all goes let me show
you to see how it plays out and I'll
report back to everybody these don't
always have a great ending and so uh
thank you so much for being brave we'll
be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back hey instead of
lyrics we got more great news
if you remember back it's about a year
ago now
Elizabeth called in and she'd been
smoking weed every day for how long
Jenna years right it was uh probably
more than 10 years I think at that point
husband was an addict and she was just
done
just done
actually I'm gonna take that back he
wasn't an addict who struggling with
addiction I've had some people in the
addiction Community reach out and say
hey man it means to a lot to us if you
say it this way instead of that way so I
want to honor that so her husband was
struggling with addiction he was smoking
weed forever too
and then she called into the show she
started changing her life and then she
reached back out and we had her back out
on the show that she was seven or eight
months sober
hadn't touched it and
she was excited that she was pregnant
and one of the reasons she wanted to
quit all the stuff that she had she
wanted to have a baby she wanted to
change her life she wanted to start a
family
and so on March 19th Elizabeth
a year plus sober now has a beautiful
little girls at it baby girl yeah
beautiful baby girl and we're we just
want to celebrate we've been on this
journey with her and her husband is
three months sober is that right yep
three months sober he stopped smoking to
prepare for the arrival of their
daughter and then since then he hasn't
gone back to it
and if there's ever a time it's right
after you have a baby
man I I it's it's these moments when
people listen to the show and they call
in and they walk alongside us and we
walk alongside them and they say never
again and they start these practices and
they start taking care of themselves and
they look up a year later and there's a
healthy baby
and two sober parents and three people
creating a life into the future that's
gonna change everything for everybody
incredible
Incredibles congratulations Elizabeth to
your amazing husband to this beautiful
little girl who's got the greatest Mom
and Dad in the world except for me and
my wife is looking awesome
congratulations and I don't know how we
how do we end this now just crank the
music up
Crank It Up Ben
hey y'all stay in school be nice to each
other be kind
tip well today pay for somebody's gas
just at the pump next year's just go
over there and put your uh debit card in
there and pay for it
should be cool high five them and walk
away
let's change this world one person at a
time we'll see you soon
[Music]